j'ai vécu une super aventure malgré que
ça a duré que trois épisodes c'était
génial je suis déjà avec Koh-Lanta trois
épisodes déjà c'est beaucoup 9 jours
c'est une bonne tasse un mois neuf jours
moi je fais pas 9 heures je te disais
c'est un rêve pour toi ouais ouais ça
fait 5 ans 50 je voulais le faire et
cette année tout à l'heure sur toi tu
fais quoi dans la vie je suis
responsable logistique dans l'automobile
dans l'automobile
et c'était ton rêve de faire Koh-Lanta
ouais ça fait cinq ans quand je suis
marié tu as des enfants je suis marié
j'ai deux enfants un petit garçon de 5
ans une petite fille de 8 mois donc
quand je suis parti à laver un mois ma
fille
donc c'est pour ça j'ai joué à fond je
perdais j'allais la retrouver donc rien
à perdre c'était des chutes partir
je me dis toujours il donne même pas un
petit coin un petit truc genre un petit
maquereau
rien du tout vraiment
8 kg en 9 jours
je transpire énormément de moyens de
base et là j'étais en haut il y avait un
taux d'humidité important et donc ouais
à couper du bois moi je m'étais attaqué
à couper beaucoup de bois et ouais j'ai
perdu 8 kilos 9 jours ouais j'étais bien
parti je restais 40 jours je finissais
sec
tu les as repris ou pas ah ouais bon par
contre dans l'autre sens ça se reprend
très rapidement
je croyais en deux semaines
en deux heures j'ai bien envie de deux
heures de retour à manger mais ouais ça
a pris deux semaines au moins un tour
c'est un super perso Alexandre tu fais
partie de l'équipe des tinago l'équipe
des rouges
ils étaient voilà les séries que
l'équipe a été beaucoup trop confiante
lors des épreuves hier soir vous allez
le voir c'est pas la modestie qui les
étouffent du coup c'était vraiment des
barres de rire regardez
les jeux vont être surpris ils vont même
pas en parler aux yeux et il a l'air
quand même vachement confiance celui-là
en même temps ils ont eu la chance de
pouvoir s'entraîner avant l'épreuve
là c'est un peu loin c'est bon j'y vais
un
j'ai assez de facilité avec l'équilibre
oh la chance et ça donne quoi un mec qui
a des facilités avec l'équilibre
s'enchaînent pour le fromage
[Musique]
qu'est-ce qu'il disait déjà le mec au
début là
alors
on aurait pu croire qu'après leur
défaite à la première épreuve les rouges
allaient arrêter de se la péter
et bien pas du tout et pour l'épreuve
d'humidité le niveau était encore pire
regardez
après avoir perdu la première épreuve
Rudy a décidé de pas partir la fleur au
fusil on est là pour la bagarre
il est important de montrer à son
adversaire que psychologiquement on
n'est pas atteint on est voir plus fort
ça va bien se passer
pour le terriblement désorganisé encore
un échec tu vas fort mon Denis là ça
peut pas être si pire que ça si
ça te va les rouges se marchent dessus
alors il dit un dernier mot
[Musique]
et c'est bien de se motiver comme ça ça
marche bien en plus
que je comprends pas vous érigez comme
grand Strateur je vais tout
révolutionner et vous êtes calme-toi
c'est un ami
moi je croyais en vous
faites complètement avoir mais qu'est-ce
qui s'est passé moi j'ai pensé que vous
vouliez retrouver vos enfants
j'avais rien à perdre j'ai tout tenté
sincèrement je voulais réaliser les
coups j'aurais rêvé de rentrer je
réalisais des coups comme ça je rentrais
dans les plus grands stratèges de
Koh-Lanta il faut y aller jusqu'au bout
et c'est dur d'assumer pour certains
d'aller jusqu'au bout d'éliminer la plus
grande sportive qu'on a dans l'équipe et
de l'assumer ah il y avait du monde pour
aller jusqu'à la première défaite il y
avait du monde et après la défaite ça
l'a fait vraiment mal à l'esprit et il y
en a après faut assumer d'éliminer la
plus grande sportive moi j'étais prêt à
le faire peut-être d'autres mois on
voulait encore j'adore parce que j'adore
j'avais l'impression
ils étaient bien sûr ils avaient bien
sûr ils sont arrivés la fleur au fusil
on y va Mbappé Mbappé qui déborde c'est
un commentateur regarde
on a pris les matchs les uns après les
autres mais voilà alors lors d'une
épreuve hier soir on sait plus trop si
on était sur TF1 ou si on était sur
Canal+ premier samedi du mois regardez
c'était une grosse grosse rigole voilà
une rage de vaincre de part et d'autre
c'est bon pour rester bas
[Musique]
tenez-moi c'est bon allez allez allez
allez
[Musique]
ça me rappelle ce soir
ça va être le même délire non c'était
sympa faire ça tu as remarqué c'est
beaucoup les jaunes qu'on voit ils
étaient plus tactile
il y a quelqu'un qui te qui te sonne
pardon merci c'est peut-être
Jean-Jacques Goldman hier soir pour ne
plus grand plaisir on a retrouvé Martin
Martin souvenez-vous c'est un peu le il
fait que le râler il avait des jours up
et des Jordan certains jours qu'on était
pas bien ouais c'était c'était plus
compliqué
il a pas de chance sur cet épisode là
c'est martyriser le pied et je peux vous
dire le truc qui faisait près de 2 m
quand quelqu'un l'enfonce dans le sable
et que c'est votre pied qui prend ça
pique un peu c'est chaud regardez cette
semaine c'était pire il était vraiment
au bout de sa vie Martin
je suis désolé je suis pas du tout de
bonne humeur meurt de faim on a rien à
bouffer sur ce camp qui a envie d'aller
me casser le cul à sortir cette poisson
dans les chaussettes tout me saoules la
Pringles
[Applaudissements]
ça faisait très loin ça faisait très mal
mais là on montre Martin mais les
premiers jours Martin il avait tout
réussi il avait réussi il avait il nous
avait guidé c'est un vrai perso et il y
a des jours où vous êtes moins bien
Koh-Lanta vous êtes obligé vous
réveiller vous avez moi un bouton de
fièvre lui ça lui provoqué vraiment des
réactions
sont ceux qui ont le plus de problèmes
de colère ou de de caprice comme ça
c'est connu ça il est assez beau il est
assez beau il a un sale caractère comme
toi
identification
et ta connerie
c'est pas d'où elle vient mais en tout
cas elle vient de loin c'est vrai oui
qu'est-ce qu'il a non mais je trouve ça
incroyable que vous avez l'air presque
Pacifique apaisé non mais vous vous êtes
fait avoir par une équipe
il vous en voulez ils vous ont c'est un
complot contre vous vous prenez vraiment
comme les Twitter à fond mais c'est un
jeu ça reste hein
après on tente des choses il faut il
faut animer c'est il faut faire des
choses mais arrêtez de croire que c'est
notre vie moi j'y allais pour jouer tout
le monde y aller c'est pour ça que
[Applaudissements]
voilà
même pas 10 minutes sur la plage
c'est parfait de la bonne attitude
qui ont dormi ensemble cette saison
est-ce qu'il y a eu des rapprochements
est-ce que ça à Ken
les images qu'on a vu c'est sur le camp
jaune moi j'étais sur le camp rouge mais
euh
sur le cochon quand on est sur le Kango
on a beaucoup parlé de dormir
c'est pas possible
c'est des techniques de survie il faut
se rapprocher la nuit pour tenir chaud
et la première nuit aussi
[Rires]
super bien la première nuit ils ont fait
un sandwich à 5 ou 6 et voilà se serrer
se tenir chaud la nuit la nuit c'était
très long et faisait très froid toi ta
ta ta ta tenue choix personne toi moi
j'étais prête sur toute ta famille
regardez-moi
j'avais interdiction de me rapprocher de
toi
Fernandel on montrait une image
justement et on sait pas forcément
de dormir comme ça avec quelqu'un est-ce
que vous pourriez danser
je vais leur donner des raisons d'avoir
je veux dire quoi est-ce que j'ai un ami
qui était cadreur dessus qui m'a dit de
toute manière il y a zéro libido quand
même quand il vous filme merci il recule
un peu tellement les odeurs sont
désagréables il y a zéro libido vous
êtes crade et tout ça c'est vrai ça et
le matin le cerveau fait vite un choix
sur la survie il y a plus rien qui monte
il y a plus rien qui vient
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
je suis en train de plus en plus et
alors je suis tiraillé parce que j'ai
vraiment envie que le PSG se qualifie
mais au moins j'aurai un kiff ouais
[Rires]
au milieu
Élodie cette semaine elle a vécu une
seule chose à faire c'est cuire du
poisson
et pas beau je vous dis Élodie une chose
est sûre on la retrouvera pas dans Top
Chef
et hier Élodie elle avait une mission
faire cuire le poisson
[Musique]
elodie a oublié de les vider
les ouvrir
de toute façon le plus chiant dans les
poissons c'est les arrêtes il y a des
arrêtes dans les poissons oui mais le
poisson il a l'air bien cuit donc ça
passe mais en fait il est pas cuit la
méthode de cuisson n'était absolument
pas la bonne
Élodie je l'adore je l'adore j'adore les
modèles sympathique ou pas énorme
c'était ma complice de l'aventure
c'est une poule d'énergie c'est
incroyable aparté autant dans la joie
que dans la peine c'était incroyable
dans les divorces
on s'est compris on était en binôme et
j'espère qu'elle va aller encore très
loin pose-lui la question de cette
première mi-temps j'ai trop envie
de faire les commentaires
très content ouais voilà c'est
incroyable d'avoir été pris sur 40 000
pour faire ça moi ça me fait qu'est-ce
qui a fait que tu as été pris je pense
le côté stratège voilà j'avais pas peur
de tenter des choses
le premier tour ça fait trois émissions
donc mais voilà j'ai tenté des choses je
suis pas resté à rien faire on verra
sûrement plus que d'autres qui vont
aller très loin je pense que les trois
épisodes ont été vraiment animé par ça
et je pense que certains spectateurs
ça faisait 20 ans qu'il voulait le faire
c'est quelque chose que je voulais
défendre aussi il y avait Célia 14 ans